hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cutting edge viral and non-viral
delivery platforms or T cell engineering
and Beyond presented by dr. Nomura
Theroux vendor senior research and
development manager at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
I'm Christie Joel of lab rats and I will
be your moderator for today's event
this presentation is brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsors please click on the thermo
Fisher logo on the left side of your
screen the presentation you are about to
see was previously recorded but I would
like to remind you this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send our speaker will be
answering your questions via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or you
may use the ask a question box to let us
know you're experiencing a problem
presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located on the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Nomura Thoreau bender dr.
Ravinder is a senior research and
development manager at Thermo Fisher
Scientific in Carlsbad California
dr. Ravinder and her team are focused on
developing platforms and workflows for
cell and gene therapy applications
including gene delivery and viral vector
systems prior to her current role she
led product development initiatives
around mammalian genome editing and
functional genomics screening as well as
helped establish a variety of custom
service offerings within Thermo Fisher
Scientific including cDNA library
generation virus production gene
expression profiling and custom RNA eye
screening tools she earned her doctorate
in biotechnology from the University of
Alabama and has ghost followed by a
postdoctoral research at Children's
Hospital in Los Angeles in HIV biology
Doctorow vendor will now begin her
presentation
you
good afternoon everyone can you all hear
me it's relatively small group so we
should be let me know back there if the
voice is clear okay good so thank you
all for joining us today I'm here from
San Diego California from the Carlsbad
site here to give you a talk on cutting
edge gene editing and delivery
technologies that we have at the Murphy
sure in our portfolio in cell biology
samih R&D leader currently leading the
delivery platform team in Carlsbad and
before then I was part of the genome
editing portfolio group leading genome
editing tool development so today's
agenda will be covering gene editing
tools just briefly going over what we
have and then primarily focusing on
CRISPR cas9 editing tool technology and
then focusing largely on what it takes
to optimize the workflow and the kind of
delivery reagents that we have for
different payloads and cell types and
then I'll end the talk focusing on some
of the viral production systems that we
have for research use as well as
clinical research use for producing
lentivirus and a V virus and then we'll
close it out with some closing comments
on the summaries so the team that is
developing gene editing tools and the
delivery reagents is located in Carlsbad
California and that is a hub for a lot
of different portfolios within thermo
Fisher including the sequencing
technologies reagents for stem cell
biology sequencing antibodies from the
legacy Affymetrix site and lot of custom
R&T services for cell engineering and
cell therapy research workflows so
before we get into the talk I just
because it's focusing largely on gene
editing workflows I just want to go
through briefly on the workflow for gene
editing as most of you might know and
for those who don't I just want to
briefly touch on this workflow
the way the gene editing tools work is
you first design a target sequence
specific gene editing moiety that would
once delivered into the cell would find
the complementary sequence that it is
supposed to bind and cut and once it
binds the sequence that we are intended
to change it the enzyme would bind and
make a double-stranded cleavage or
single strand depending on the kind of
tool that you're using and once the
double-stranded cleavage is made at a
specific sequence the rest you're
leaving it to the cells repair mechanism
where it can leverage to major repair
mechanisms one of them called the
non-homologous end joining mechanism
where that the double-stranded break
region can come back together and during
this process of repair it's largely
error-prone creating lot of frame shifts
thereby knocking out the genes function
the other repair mechanism called as the
homology driven repair mechanism that
can be leveraged in the presence of a
donor DNA where you will insert the
sequence that you want to use for
repairing the mutation and what-have-you
within the cells so once in the presence
of the DNA the homology driven repair
mechanism kicks in so what it does is
now you have a double-stranded DNA you
have a donor repair donor and that donor
can be stitched into that double
stranded region making precise edits
edits that you would like either a snip
change you could add a promoter of your
choice or an exogenous DNA that you want
to express inside the cells of choice so
those are the major repair mechanisms
there are other types and then at thermo
Fisher the gene editing tools that we
provide we have two major ones tell in
nucleases and the CRISPR caste 9 nucleus
is I'll be focusing mostly on CRISPR
cast 9 and I'll go through the biology
for some of you who may not be aware of
this and then we also provide gene
synthesis services through gene art
which where you could provide your
sequence of interest that you want to
use for correction for knocking in a
particular gene of interest or a
mutation and then that particular DNA
can be synthesized either as fragments
or as plasmids
so now within this workflow of gene
editing that if you divide those
workflows your three major categories
you're designing the payload right
either the cash mine or the talents what
have you or the donor DNA you design it
and then you order that particular
reagent and then you're delivering it
the piece of delivery is very critical
that you really need to make the right
choice of delivery reagents you're
either looking at your cell types or
you're looking at the payload that
you're trying to deliver either the DNA
or a protein version or RNA that you're
trying to transmit into the cell and
once you have used an efficient delivery
reagent then the next step is to wait
for those payloads to do its job and
then you're detecting and then using it
for downstream workflow so now if you
look into this workflow in more detail
for gene editing after using the editing
tool you're preparing them the next step
after transfecting is you're looking at
the editing efficiency inside the cell
and then depending on your workflow
you're using these cells that have been
edited for a disease model or you have a
drug discovery path that you're trying
to take using a library screening either
ways your main goal is to maximize
editing efficiency and why would you
want to maximize it in efficiency let's
take the scenario of making disease
models if you have a pool of cells
higher the editing efficiency higher the
success rate of finding the edited clone
that you want so the less number of
clones to screen so that is the key and
to do this it's very important that you
have the right payload that will enable
you to have the highest editing
efficiency the right protocol the right
media that is suitable for the cells and
the right delivery agents so what we do
as we are developing these reagents one
of the key focus for the R&D team is to
make sure not to just develop the tools
but also ensuring that we have cell
type-specific protocols with all of the
media's and the transfection reagents
and downstream analysis so that is the
goal and that's where we
spend most of your most of our time in
doing a product development to ensure
that we get really robust protocols not
just the product that goes into the
customers hand but a protocol that is
suitable for our customers so you will
see some examples for what we have done
the case studies of where we have used
these kind of approaches for having
optimized editing efficiency for stem
cells or T cells and so on and so forth
so before we get into that since we will
be touching about different aspects and
factors within the cast nine system I
want to briefly go through what the
CRISPR cast nine system is this is a
bacterial adaptive immune response based
gene editing tool where the scientists
to keep it brief the scientists have
leveraged this system that drives immune
response in bacteria against viruses
they have taken that and use the
components from there for mammalian
genome editing in several different host
you know meriting including plants and
other hosts so the two main components
that are needed for gene editing in
CRISPR cast nine is that purple bubble
that you see the cash nine enzyme and
the yellow hairpin loop structure that
you see there the guide RNA the cash
nine is the enzyme that actually helps
in cleaving the DNA the gene ohmic DNA
of interest what drives the specificity
is the guide RNA so if you focus on the
guide RNA region you should see two
components there one the target specific
region the yellow line there which is
about twenty bases specific to the
genomic sequence of interest so if you
have a particular gene that you're
trying to edit you find a unique twenty
base pair region and then design your
guide RNA for that region the rest of
the guide RNA which is called the tracer
RNA is constant component that is
required for functionality and structure
okay so once you've identified the
twenty bases it's almost like designing
a PCR primer you deliver that and you
deliver the casting either as a plasmid
or a protein or an mRNA that can be
expressed thereafter and then inside the
cell the cast nine is the guide RNA
combined together to form what's called
as the ribonucleoprotein complex
now this complex is scanning through the
genome and it's looking for ngg sequence
in the genome that's called the pam site
and this pam site is unique the ngg
sequence is unique but the CRISPR cas9
system from streptococcus pyogenes for
other putress podcast may the fan sites
are different so now the cache line and
guide RNA complex is scanning the genome
sisa ngg sequence then it's trying to
match the upstream 20 bases to the guide
RNA to see if the guide RNA is
complementary if it doesn't it's going
through and scanning until it finds the
respective complementary sequence within
the genome that you're trying to design
the guide RNA for once it finds it it
binds to that region the enzyme gets
active and makes a double-stranded
cleavage with the wild-type cast nine
because it has to cutting sites within
it so now what's really critical the
first step in designing the genome
editing tool is designing the right
guide RNA so what we have done and
you'll see very similar the others in
the field have worked a lot on designing
guide RNAs they're different rules for
guide RNA designing the first step is to
find you take every gene of interest
within the human genome if you want to
create a library of guidance for human
genome you would look at all the genes
take all possible guide RNAs that a
unique sequences meaning you have that
20 base pairs only at that intended side
but not elsewhere otherwise you will
have off target right once you find all
possible guide armies you take those
guide RNA that have five prime region if
you want to knock out a gene if you're
just silencing the gene you're trying to
focus mostly towards the five prime so
that you are cutting that genome early
on so that you can knock down the
message downstream and then once you
take those five prime regions you're
also looking at off target effects
you're trying to look at one or two or
three base pair differences and then
will this sequence bind elsewhere in the
genome and you do the off-target
analysis and you're also looking at
binding efficiencies of these the GC
content because sometimes if you have
stronger GC content the binding of the
guy
genome is much stronger so even if you
have one base pair difference within
that 20 bases and you have a sequence
similar elsewhere in the genome the
chances are it will bind stronger so
there's a fine balance of the GC content
so once you do all of this what we do
for the knockout libraries is we would
take the top four unique guide RNAs and
use that for gene knockouts so you can
take one two or three guide RNAs to
knock out the gene so that is for gene
knocking out so we have a library so one
could buy those guidance from the
library participate gene of interest but
if you're doing knocking in when you're
doing precise cutting what you need to
do is you're not going to look at the
Phi prime region you're looking at the
region that you want to make the
mutation at right and then you will pick
that sequence and then you're trying to
blast that sequence and find a unique
region now we have a tool within thermo
Fisher that can help you to design
unique guide RNAs for knocking in so
once you've done these designs your next
step is to pick the right cast 9 format
so if you look at in the field and
within thermo Fisher we have gone
through a journey of developing cache
lines in different formats having cast 9
being expressed from a plasmid so once
you have that plasmid transfected into
the cell they'll express within the cell
the mRNA and then the protein and then
the field moved to going from the
plasmids to the mRNA because plasmid DNA
there is a concern of random integration
because if the DNA stays in the cell for
too long it's constantly expressing the
caste 9 until the DNA is cleared from
the system therefore what happens is the
caste 9 does its job cuts the genome but
it's also there to go and look for other
sites so the chances for off-target are
much higher when you have plasmid system
so therefore the TR the field and so did
we move to the cash 9 mrna system and
then tune what we have the industry
standard right now is the cash 9 are in
P system where you have the cash man is
pure purified protein recombinant
protein and the guide RNA as RNA so now
you have a DNA free system that sets you
up for success to
have highest editing efficiency and also
lowest off-target so now depending on
the kind of payload you use the delivery
reagents and the delivery method will be
different so if you're using a plasmid
based system you would go for lipo
fective in 3000 if you're using mRNA you
would go for a delivery reagent that is
specific for mRNA like affect him in
messenger mat and for protein the
curious podcast 9 are in P system you
would go for a CRISPR max delivery
system those are the lipid based
reagents for transfection
they're really nice when you're doing
high throughput screenings and etc and
for relatively less challenging cell
types when you are dealing with primary
cells and more difficult in challenging
cell types then you would want to use
the electroporation system and what we
have is a neon electroporation system
and you will see some examples of using
this in primary T cells and iPS ES and
so on and so forth we also have viral
wave based delivery system and you'll
see those examples later on we have
lentiviral system as well as in
development we also have an AAV
adeno-associated virus system production
systems to make viruses that can be used
as gene delivery vectors for different
cell types of interest again the key
here is always remember the payload that
you're using and based on the payload
you want to choose the transfection
reagents because if you think of these
transfection reagents the way they are
designed is our developed is screening
those for a fit for purpose for that
particular format that you're trying to
deliver within the cell so what we have
done this is just an example to show in
a journey of designing guide RNAs the
first goal was to make sure we have
highly efficient guide RNAs in are
CRISPR libraries so in that case when
you're trying to design and screen the
guide RNA that is having highest
efficiency if you have a caste 9
expressing cells so you have a cell that
already has a cash 9 expressing as a
stable cell line then all you're doing
is you're delivering a guide RNA into
the cell so you're just delivering the
RNA so you use a life of ectomy RNA I'm
at
the agent that is specifically designed
to deliver RNA into the smell small RNAs
in this case the guide RNAs which are
about 100 nucleotides in length so this
is an example just to show that we have
tried in this particular cell line
different guide RNAs to see what is the
editing efficiency for that particular
guide RNA now the next example here is
just to show that for as I mentioned for
plasmid DNA
it's like effect amine 3000 this is just
showing you that we had thermo Fisher we
did have different older versions of
transfection reagents like like effect
amine 3000 2000 and compared to like
affect him in 2000 when we had Chris
Perry agents we wanted to make sure we
develop reagents that like even more
robust and we screened different
reagents and we found like perfect amine
3000 to be much more robust than 2000
and this example is just showing GFP
plasmid using one of the competitor
agents in the field few gene alongside
life of ectomy in 2000 our older
generation plasmid DNA and then the life
of ectomy 3000 again as I said earlier
plasmid DNA we have very good
transduction reagents but when you're
doing gene editing you really want high
gene editing efficiencies so it's always
best to go and use the cast 9
ribonucleoprotein are in P system where
you can take me for a cast 9 protein as
as a purified recombinant protein and
the guide RNA as RNA and the reason why
we would like that is if you think about
DNA the DNA has to enter into the cell
the cast 9 has to express and then it
has to find the RNA and in the right 1/2
1 molar ratio so you're leaving that
ratio finding the right ratio to the to
the cell to decide same thing in mRNA
when you deliver cast 9 mRNA it gets
into the cell it has to express the
protein and the protein has to find the
guide RNA sin 1 2 1 molar ratio in case
of the cast 9 protein and guide RNA when
you're trying to translate it into the
cell you already have the protein ready
to go and act and before delivering it
into the cell you can complex the cast 9
protein and the guide RNA
one-to-one molar ratio and form the RMP
complex in your reaction tubes so you
can control that molar ratios you are
setting yourself up for success before
transferring that into the cell so it is
ready to act and you have it in the
right molar ratio and in addition it
doesn't have the same threat like the
plasmids of randomly integrating into
the cell right and also what you could
do with the protein you can just give
enough amount of protein needed for
optimal gene editing and what you will
see on the right side the Western blot
there shows you this is an example from
two nine threes just to show you the
amount of protein that is expressed with
the DNA so you are taking your
normalizing the DNA mRNA and the caste 9
protein to the equal amount of editing
efficiency so you have the same amount
of proteins when you're delivering and
you if you have your DNA what's
happening is the DNA is constantly
expressing the protein from 0 to 72
hours the level of protein is increasing
in the cell so what that means is after
the editing happens the editing happens
what we notice is as early as 12 hours
to 24 hours sometimes depending on the
cell type so the editing happens and the
protein is still left over to go and
attack other off target sites so you're
increasing the chances of after get more
with the DNA version and if you look at
the mRNA it remains constant because it
controlling the dose of the mRNA protein
you deliver the protein you have a high
peak of the protein in the beginning
because you're adding that into the cell
and as time passes it turns over so what
that means is it does its job and the
protein is then removed from the cell
much faster so you would want to go with
the RNP system to increase your
efficiencies and then clear the protein
from the system so that you don't allow
it to do any off targets and down below
the graph there actually shows examples
of two different off target sites for
the specific guide RNA we were using in
this case so what you see here is
with the DNA you can see much higher
editing efficiency or both the off
target sites whereas the protein barely
has any cutting efficiency at that site
so in this experiment what we are trying
to do is you're intentionally designing
a guide RNA that has that's not that
unique but has potential off target
you're designing a bad guide RNA to just
look at the off-target effect in a in
reality when you're doing your
experiment you wouldn't do that right
this is just to show that the DNA a
based approach has higher off target
activity than the protein so long story
short what you really want is design a
good guide RNA and go with a caste 9 are
in P system to increase your editing
efficiency here are just whole bunch of
examples to show that the caste 9 are in
P system and used with the lipo effect
Amin CRISPR max again this is the lipid
based reagent you can cover most of the
cell types example shown here as a Phi
498 here in cells some suspension cells
like th p1 and then couple other edge or
in cells at the bottom so pretty robust
editing efficiency across different
guide RNAs or different gene sequences
that we have tested this is one example
showing hprt r-la an AVS one three
different genes that we were trying to
target its PRP and a vs1 are intronic
regions and the rel a is a exonic
sequence and the first graph what you
trying what I'm trying to show you here
is the comparison between the plasmid
based system and the calf nine RMP
system barrier using the Casa 9 protein
and the guide RNA and you can see hprt
is a really robust site and with the DNA
what you when you get into really tough
cell types like FG to the suspension
cells with a high with a really robust
delivery system which is neon
electroporation you still cannot get
over 10 percent editing efficiency in
these cases whereas with cash 9 protein
system you can all almost go up to 90%
anything efficiency depending on the
target type just to show you an example
that more difficult cell types you you
start using the power
the efficiency is not that great you
want to switch to the RMP not only for
our off target but also for highest
editing efficiency on the right side the
graph is just showing an example of like
effect Amin crisper max with cast 9 R
and P and we have used we have optimized
the media the protocols and we have a
fit for purpose protocol for this
particular case and you're comparing
with equally good competitor reagent and
trying to see how we perform and what we
see is when we have optimized protocols
our RMP system with our robust protocols
that we have works much more efficient
than what's out there in the field now
what I want to show next is the real
advantage and the use of these editing
tools is in terracotta therapies or
making isogenic tells disease models
with IPS see so for those of you are not
aware of what isogenic disease models
are in case of IPS you can take a wild
type cell you can differentiate that
into whatever tissue that you are
interested in in studying the disease
model and then you can take the same
wild-type IPS see cell create a diseased
mutant and create an IPS see that is a
mutant variety now and then now
differentiate that into the disease
model with that specific disease
relevant mutations so now you have from
the same parental cell line you have the
Y type as well as a mutant disease model
so you're creating an ISO genic disease
model from the same genome ik background
as opposed to taking two different
patients who are different coming from
different genetic backgrounds I know
different regions you have much more
complexity there so the beauty of gene
editing is really that you can create
isogenic models using IPS ES and then do
your comparative studies in that
background so I just want to show you an
example of what we have done during the
development process so we had our cash 9
reagents we have different media's and
a/c systems for specific for IPS ES and
different transfection reagents that are
specific so we have lipo factor means
stem lipid base reagent forecast 9 RMP
transaction and then
cause neon to boost the editing
efficiency even more so what we have
done our first journey in developing the
protocol for IPS es was we used the neon
after optimizing our conditions with
lipid-based system we moved on to the
electroporation system the neon system
the beauty of the neon system is it has
24 predefined electroporation conditions
with different voltages and so on and so
forth so when you are beginning to
optimize your condition you can take a
control guide RNA we do offer different
controls like HP RT and others you can
take a control guide RNA use the right
media system in the transfer transaction
conditions test all of the 24 pick the
best transaction condition in this case
we have picked a few different
conditions and then what you see here is
the optimal condition for DNA optimal
condition for mRNA and different dosages
of protein with a specific condition
that we have optimized for
electroporation and as you can see the
editing efficiency with kaznia an RNP
system is much higher compared to the
mRNA or DNA even after using the best
conditions for each of those so this is
just to give you an example that you
really need to spend a lot of time
upfront to optimize your conditions even
if you have the best editing reagent
Attis function reagents you want to make
it cell type-specific so that's where we
spend most of our time
here is another example showing two
different graphs that you you'll notice
here one in red is the in dell that is
knockout so you're using cash 9 RMP
system with electroporation to knock out
the gene cutting a specific gene so
there are different types of genes here
and the second the purple graph that you
see is for the same side you're
inserting specific mutations so you're
doing precise gene edits at that locus
so first if you look at the knocking out
efficiency depending on the target that
you are it's also target specific the
editing efficiency so it's not just the
reagents that you use but also the
target sequence that you're trying to
edit and that's one of the reasons why
we always recommend
our customers to design at least two if
not three guide RNAs for each specific
locus that you're testing and pick the
one that is the best okay and similarly
when you go for even though you have
really high gene knockout efficiency you
still have to make sure that you're
knocking inefficiency so good and if you
look at the HDR efficiency again
depending on the site and the sequence
that you're trying to edit the editing
efficiencies can vary anywhere between
you know 20% to 80% for knocking out and
then five to 40% for knocking in so what
we have been doing now that we have all
these good reagents and workflows our
focus is to really boost that knocking
inefficiency because that is where the
field is moving to make precise edits we
are trying to identify new molecules
that can boost editing efficiency by
electroporation and that's where most of
our work right now is focused on so the
next example that I want to focus on
here is t-cell primary t-cell editing so
before the R and P times we barely were
getting any good editing efficiency it
was really single-digit numbers so with
the with a good are in P system that we
have and a good condition of neon
electroporation what we then decided to
do is build a workflow specific protocol
so in this example we use our CT as
grade the cell therapy systems grade
dynabeads to isolate the T cells we also
have T cell activation beat based
activation kits for isolating T cells as
well as activating T cells so you really
need to activate the T cells before you
edit so after three days of activation
of the T cells that have been isolated
you then transfect our electro parade
these cells the primary T cells
activated T cells with the cash nine RNP
okay so in this case what we're trying
to do is if you are if you're familiar
with the car T space the TCR receptors
are one of the favorite target sites for
editing so here we have used
two different guide RNAs for TCR alpha
chain and two different guide RNAs for
TCR beta chain as you can see depending
on the sequence of that site that you're
doing the editing efficiency can vary so
once you've selected the best guide RNA
then you go back and do your real
experiment so the first what we do is we
want to make sure the T cells that we
have isolated are really T cells so you
I'm just showing a snippet of the data
here so in this case we are looking at
if you have really good T cell isolation
you should have greater than 90 percent
TCR positive cells I'm doing flow
cytometry here using antibodies against
the TCR receptor so in an untranslated
cell i sure i should have over 90% TCR
positive and that's what I see in my on
transfect example now when I use a cash
9 RMP that is specific to TCR receptor a
guy down is specific to that receptor
and if I have high gene editing
efficiency I should see a leftward shift
of all of those cells so TCR negative
populations as you can see on the
rightmost graph we really have over 90%
editing efficiency which is really
strong efficiency right there and that's
what you want because ultimately you're
trying to add these engineer T cells
into a horse cell and you want to
maximize your chance of getting the
effect that you intend to see so this is
just knocking out a gene the beauty of
gene editing is again by making precise
edits so then what we did we also wanted
before we did specific mutations we also
wanted to see the efficiency of
multiplexing so in this case we are
trying to knock out PCR gene b2m gene
which is specific to the MHC complex
which is also another favorite target
that is not out for party workflows and
then pd-1 so these three targets what we
are trying to see in this experiment is
if I translate these guide RNAs
individually versus I divide the total
amount of guide RNA that I might rhyme
transfecting
divide that into three different guide
RNAs will I get equal efficiencies or do
I need to boost the amount of guide RNA
for each so if you look at the graphs
here what you will see the purple graphs
right there are single guy darkness that
means each well I have only one guide
RNA for that particular cell type and
then the red bars I have another well
with all of the three guide RNAs pooled
together so basically you're taking the
cache line and all three guide armies
into one tube mixing them you're
dividing the total amount of guide RNA
molar amounts that you have into all
three and that's the fourth well and
when I'm doing my editing efficiency
poster transfection 48 hours later I
harvest the cells and I'm doing NGS
sequencing either taking that single
guide RNA and sequencing that specific
locus for that single RNA or taking the
pool samples where I have all three
guide RNA and then doing the sequencing
for all three targets and as you can see
here whether I transfect as single
guides or I have only one-third the
amount in multiplex I have equal amount
of editing efficiency again long story
short here what I'm trying to the
message that I'm trying to deliver here
is because of the efficiency of our NPS
you really don't need that much amount
of R and P now you can multiplex your
experiments we have tried up to six
guide RNAs in a single experiment and
then looked at editing efficiency in
multiplexing so if you see again the
flow cytometry experiment I start off
with strong T C are positive and B 2 and
positive cells as I do my knockouts I
should start seeing T C are negative and
B to M negative population right there
and I'm getting close to 70% multiplex
samples with all three you don't see the
PD one here but we are getting over 60%
with all three guide RNAs knocking out
all three sides so the next one now is
looking at the knockin in a fish
so in this case we are taking t-cells
and trying to add a orange fluorescent
protein downstream of an actin promoter
okay so we're trying to knock out the
beta-actin site and then cut that site
and add a 1.4 kb ofp gene sequence so if
you notice this controls again I'm
looking this is at the TCR site and
sorry so in this side you see TCR
positive to begin with and now I'm
trying to knock out the cells I should
see TCR negative population which is
pretty good by knocking up now in the
knockin sample what I see with the
regular transfection electroporation
buffer are barely getting any knocking
in efficiency of my ofp protein which is
about 5% so what we have done then is we
wanted to improve this efficiency we
screens several small molecules that can
boost the knockin efficiency and what
you see in the rightmost graphed
flow cytometry data is by using this
delivery buffer called our buffer with a
small molecule in there that is boosting
the editing efficiency from 5% to close
to 20% knocking inefficiency so we are
able to increase by several folds and
knock inefficiency so these are the kind
of efforts that we are doing within R&D
to see what else can we do to boost
knockin so using cell type specific
delivery reagent cash 9 our MP and the
our buffer with small molecule that can
boost knocking inefficiency we are able
to get over 20% not in efficiencies we
are doing similar type of experiments
for different cell types to see if we
can have cell type-specific buffers with
the right formulation of the molecules
to small molecules to boost editing
efficiency in different cell types so
again several different papers that you
will see for neon conditions but I'll go
into the last two 2 to 3 slides that I
have is focusing changing gears from
cash 9 RNP to the viral vector
production system again the gene therapy
world the
lentivirus and the AV systems are pretty
favorite in the field and the goal there
now for us is to provide production
systems with the cells that have been
screened for lentiviral production or AV
production with the right transfection
reagent right media and the complex
ation buffers so that our customers when
they buy that combination of kids you
can have a good production system to
boost your titers so we launched what we
call the lv max system as a research
grade use product and then followed that
where the CTA is great for cell therapy
systems - for your GMP workflows so
customers can use this particular system
and scale up to make large-scale into
viral production so you can do anywhere
from 96 well format to 2 liters or
bioreactors larger than that to produce
virus titers of 1 times 10 to the 8th or
more okay so again from our experiences
that we have learned from the lentiviral
system we now then want to go into the
adeno-associated virus systems and what
we are working on right now that's in
development is the AV mac system so what
we have done here we have these are all
suspension cell based production systems
so we have taken our XP to nine three
cells screen them and picked clones that
are effective producers of a a a V and
then use those cell types so you have in
this kit suspension cells that have been
built specifically for increasing AV
production and then we have enhancers to
boost the transfection and so that you
get good titers towards the end we have
a suitable transfection reagent that
have been specifically formulated and
the protocol is optimized for having
really robust titers of a V and then
along with this what we have also done
is some work on the lysis buffer so
usually in the fields where people are
making these a B what they do is some
times they have to centrifuge the cells
and then isolate the harvest think about
bio reactors that are large you cannot
do the centrifugation so what we have
done with the lysis buffer is directly
adding this lysis buffer into the
culture so you can lyse the cells in
cell culture and then use it downstream
for either tff or other downstream
process we are also working with
collaborators within the company with
the between the purification side and
trying to build that protocol from all
the way from producing the virus to
getting the right protocols for
purification using a porous forms so not
only building the cell of the production
system for virus production but also
having the workflow from end to end so
again this is a scalable suspension
system animal origin free right now we
are in development but you can get early
access to this production system we are
offering the beta sister beta version
for beta testing if you want to do your
PD work process development and then we
will support you through the journey
from all the way to the CTS version for
GMP workflows when we have that so I am
going to skip this slide and go to the
last one this is just to show you an
example again av there are several
different 0 types depending on the
tissue that you want to target so what
we have done is after optimizing and
building this production system just
like you have seen we spend a lot of R&D
and research to really make fit for
purpose protocols and in this case
you're seeing using our in development
product that we have we've tested it
across different 0 types a v2 AV 6 d j 8
& 9 and what you're seeing in this graph
is what people have been doing is mostly
they use 2 9 3 t systems and we are
comparing that to the suspension version
with the AV max and as you can see with
1.5 microgram per well in this well
format you can get equal or better than
the 2/9 head to 9 3 t systems so here
the message here is as we work in
product development it's
just to get that reagent where there's a
transfection reagent or viral production
system in the hands of the customer we
do understand the pain pain points from
designing and editing to if it is gene
editing with CRISPR cast nine all the
way to different factors like media
transaction reagents and downstream
processes very similar for the viral
production we are going through that
journey of making sure we have the right
protocols to get the really high titers
but also making sure that the downstream
purification protocols are fit for
purpose so that's where we are focusing
our efforts so if you have any questions
I'm still here for another we have 15 15
minutes more for Q&A s and I'm happy to
answer and do some deep dives if you're
interested I'll be outside the theater
for any other questions that you have
and with that I would take some
questions that you might have
[Applause]
you
a big thank you goes out to doctor
for her excellent presentation mentor
audience if you do have any questions
you would like to ask please type them
in the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
dr. Ravinder will be answering these
questions via the email address you
provided at the time of registration I
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on to the end
and laboratory via email when it's
available to replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon have a great day